هناك حرب للتصريحات اشعلت بالفعل هذه
الحرب بين الديمقراطيين
والجمهوريين واول من انتقد هذا القرار هو
رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي الجمهوري كيفن
مكارسي الذي اكد ان المدعي العام في منهات
الديمقراطي اضر ببلاده بشكل لا يمكن
اصلاحه في محاوله للتدخل في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه حسب قوله ويشاركه في وجهه نظره
روندي سانتس المنافس الابرز الترامب في
انتخابات 20 24 الرئاسيه والذي وصف
توجيهها الاتهامات للرئيس السابق بانه
مناف للقيم الامريكيه في المقابل اشاد
ديمقراطيون بنظام العداله الامريكي الذي
تمكن بحسب ما يقولون من مقادات رئيس سابق
اعتبر زعيم الديمقراطيين في مجلس الشيوخ
جاك شومر ان ترامب يخضع لنفس القوانين
التي يخضع لها كل امريكي مشيرا الى انه
سيتمكن من الاستفاده من النظام القانوني
لت مصيره وفقا للوقائع والقانون من جانبها
شددت رئيسه مجلس النواب الامريكي السابقه
نانسي بيلوسي على ان هيئه المحلفين الكبرى
تصرفت بناء على الحقائق والقانون مؤكده ان
لا احد فوق القانون